le préfet de police de paris didier n'a
didier lallement se livre-t-il à des
pratiques illégales dans sa gestion du
maintien de l'ordre
c'est la question posée par nos
confrères de médiapart le journal
affirme s'être procuré des notes
internes de responsables de la
gendarmerie nationale et de responsables
de compagnies de crs
leur constat serait accablant il parle
de pratiques douteuses d'emploi
disproportionné de la force ou encore
d'ordre dangereux alors à y at il un
problème l'allemand aucun selon
christophe castaner comme il l'avait
affirmé le 19 février et pour en parler
nous retrouvons jean pierre colombie
ancien commandant de police jean pierre
colombie bonjour merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors que
l'article de mediapart pose la question
et y at il un problème de violences
policières en france selon ce alors si
on s'en tient aux termes de l'article
que quand j'ai pris connaissance pas
plus tard que ce matin du reste et si
les informations qui sont reprises dans
le cadre de cet article à savoir qu'il y
aurait une évolution de la doctrine
d'emploi des forces de sécurité on va
dire des forces de maintien de l'ordre
au travers d' instructions données par
le préfet de police à pose effectivement
un problème sérieux pour ne pas dire un
problème grave jusqu'à nouvel ordre
jusqu'à maintenant les doctrines
d'emploi sont claires elles sont
toujours bien appliquées par les
services du maintien de l'ordre crs ou
gardes mobiles et ça depuis depuis très
longtemps on n'a jamais été confrontés à
une évolution de ce genre là si
réellement ce qui est indiqué à savoir
que l'on sollicite ses forces
d'intervention d'aller à paqueter les
manifestants de ne pas hésiter à
organiser des nas c'est très grave ça
pose un problème véritablement de
philosophie d'emploi des forces de
maintien de l'ordre et au delà de ça 2
deux philosophies de gouvernement de
gouvernance globale il faut bien
imaginer que si le préfet de police a
décidé d'évoluer dans ce sens là il n'a
peut-être pas fait seul et c'est très
dangereux parce que ça veut dire que le
système qui est le nôtre qui a été le
nôtre jusqu'à maintenant est en train
d'évoluer d'évoluer vers quoi toute la
question est là et il serait trop facile
lorsqu'il ya des débordements sur le
terrain que la responsabilité en incombe
uniquement aux individus aux agents qui
risquent de déraper parce qu'il ya un
vrai risque de dérapages et de
s'exonérer de ses débordements et de ses
excès ce que vous appelez les violences
policières ce serait trop simple
l'agent qui est sur le terrain lui ne
fait qu'obéir à une chaîne de
commandement qui va de son officier haut
commissaire g jusqu'au préfet de policé
pour ne pas dire jusqu'au ministre qui
doit assumer ses responsabilités encore
en tant que donneur d'ordre on ne peut
pas se contenter de faire le procès une
manière univoque aux agents qui sont
confrontés à des situations de
crispation ou dont on a fait en sorte
qu'elles risquent justement
donc il faudra que chacun se reconnaisse
chacun assume ses responsabilités et si
véritablement ce qui est indiqué dans
l'article est avérée et bien fait qu'il
s'en explique et qui s'en explique
devant la population mais peut être
aussi un moment donné devant les
tribunaux parce que s'il ya un
glissement illégal l'ordre illégal est
prévu il est prévu que l'ordre est il
légal doit être poursuivi chacun devra
en répondre devant la loi si c'est
nécessaire et donc devant les magistrats
alors jean pierre columbia je vous
parlais de philosophie justement et dans
une enquête du monde du 23 février on
apprend que la boussole de didier
lallement et le code d'honneur de la
légion étrangère alors partir au combat
militaire ou partir au maintien de
l'ordre
est ce qu'il faut le même état d'esprit
selon vous écoutez je ne sais pas s'il
faut en sourire ou en rire ou en pleurer
mais s'ils sont sa base de valeurs c'est
le code de la légion je crois
véritablement que là pour le coup on ne
sait pas de quoi on parle le code
d'honneur de la légion c'est combattre
et mourir
c'est une forme de gérer parce que de
formes d'action suicidaire jure
la légion a inscrit des lettres de
bravoure au cours de notre histoire mais
mais quel rapport
quel rapport entre la légion étrangère
les combats qu'elle a pu mener
que ce soit sur tous les terrains
d'opération notamment dien bien phu et
les manifestations le rapport avec les
manifestants décidément si réellement ce
monsieur ce préfet de police a intégré
cette philosophie d'emploi des hommes
comme on commet la légion étrangère
c'est-à-dire jusqu'au bout jusqu'à la
mort c'est inquiétant c'est très
inquiétant et là vraiment il faut
envoyer des signaux d'alarmé au ministre
de l'intérieur et aux présidents
parce que se nommer un préfet de police
n'est pas vous imaginez bien que du
ressort du ministre de l'intérieur s'est
véritablement ou quelque chose qui est
du ressort de la responsabilité globale
du pouvoir qui va du ministre de
l'intérieur jusqu'au président de la
république dont chacun de voir et
reconnaître les siens et lorsque préfet
de police emploi ces termes et se
revendique de cette philosophie c'est
très grave de mon point de vue c'est
très grave parce que la police ou les
forces de matières nobles ou ne sont pas
l'armée et encore moins la légion
étrangère qui est le jusqu'au boutisme
de l'acte militaire donc ce vraiment pas
en garde à ce que l'on dit les mots dans
une autre période aujourd'hui ont une
importance très lourde et il faut qu'ils
apprennent parfois peut-être à se taire
ou à peser le sens de leurs propos et en
l'occurrence ça peut aller très loin
c'est très grave de mon point de vue
c'est très grave alors en ce qui
concerne les commandants d'unités sur le
terrain est ce qu'ils ont la possibilité
de désobéir selon leur conscience à un
ordre qu'il juge inappropriés voire
dangereux ben c'est très compliqué c'est
très compliqué de désobéir le sens du
désobéissent mans est très complexe
vous vous êtes faut bien se mettre à la
place des agents qui sont sur le terrain
je parle de des agents des gardiens de
la paix du gardien de la paix à
l'officier supérieur
c'est très complexe vous imaginez bien
que désobéir n'est pas une chose ça mais
c'est peut-être pourquoi le préfet de
l'allemand fait une référence est si
lourde à l'institution militaire dans
l'armée on il ya un adage qui est très
clair c'est un ordre donné est un ordre
exécuté ses sets ça c'est de ça dont on
parle de cette philosophie d'emplois
théoriquement le code pénal je dirais le
code de déontologie est très clair si
vous recevez un ordre illégal ou
inappropriés vous
devez pas vous y soumettre en d'autres
termes vous devez désobéir et je pense
et j'espère que les individus officiers
ou commissaires qui sont dans le cadre
d'un cadre républicain qui est le leur
donc vraiment ça en tête et de se dire
de se rappeler qu'ils défendent la
république et qui défendent l'intérêt
général et à ce titre
désobéir ou adapter l'ordre qu'on vous a
donné aux nécessités du terrain est une
obligation vous n'êtes pas obligé de
respecter un ordre illégal ou tout
simplement un ordre idiot ça n'a pas de
sens il faut vraiment un moment donné
prendre ses propres responsabilités à
titre individuel et quel que soit le
grade que l'on est
alors pour conclure jean pierre
colombiès est ce qu'un audit du maintien
l'ordre aujourd'hui seraient nécessaires
selon moi il serait nécessaire jeu il
est même il serait même surprenant qu'
il n'y ait pas des débriefings régulier
sur les événements auxquels on assiste
depuis maintenant un an et demi enfin
posons nous la bonne question est ce
qu'il est normal que notre pays
connaisse une période d'instabilité de
crispation depuis un an et demi depuis
la crise des gilet jaune ça parce qu'on
a appelé la crise et gilet jaune l'état
la société est sous tension n'en
rajoutons pas en laissant des prises de
paroles de ce niveau là on nous ment des
gens qui ont ce type de philosophie qui
mortifère
il faut véritablement poser des choses
mais encore faut-il qu'ils aient une
bonne autorités politiques au bon poste
et que c'est personnel politique et la
capacité de faire une analyse de ce qui
est en train de se passer
maintenant si on considère que quoi
qu'il advienne quelles que soient les
mécontentements on se contentera de
poser une population en colère des
forces de police ou de maintien de
l'ordre globalement de maintien de nos
forces et gendarmerie ça pose des
questions très lourde et très grave est
ce que notre démocratie n'est pas en
train d'évoluer
et si oui dans quel sens et je crois que
ce qui est annoncé nous annonce que la
direction qui est prise est la pire qui
soit probablement merci jean pierre
colombiès d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien commandant de police